this was the airstrike on a high-rise
block in northern gaza that killed a
senior commander of the palestinian
islamic jihad group
at least eight others were also killed
including a five-year-old girl more than
50 people were injured
the funerals of the dead took place
within hours of the airstrikes
a number of observation posts along the
border were also hit in strikes
this is a declaration of all-out war
against the palestinian people we will
respond to that this is a violation of
disregard for all the efforts that we
have made over the past days in order to
restore calm
the israeli military said that it
decided to act first after days of
threats from palestinian islamic jihad
following the arrest of one of their
leaders in the west bank on monday night
following that roads were closed and a
lockdown imposed on the israeli side of
the border to protect israelis living
nearby
but it also allowed israel to move
military equipment into position close
to gaza in preparation for this
operation
hello
this government has a zero tolerance
policy for any attempted attacks of any
kind from gaza towards israeli territory
terrorist organizations will not set the
agenda in an envelope we will not accept
any threat to the residents
[Applause]
key to what happens next will be the
response from hamas the militant group
which controls gaza
israel says it wants the operation to be
limited and it told hamas via back
channels that they were not the target
but if hamas decides to join forces with
palestinian islamic jihad and attack
israel
things could escalate very quickly
much will depend on the next 24 hours
alastair bunker sky news